can it smell what's in the air very
slowly this turtle makes its way across
one of the largest vanilla plantations
in northern Madagascar you can't miss
the Christmas smell here coming from the
vanilla pods that are laid out every
morning to dry in the Sun cultivating
vanilla is laborious but also lucrative
several hundred thousand euros worth of
the pods are laid out here
it's Madagascar's very own black gold
meat hen who's of Chinese descent has
been in the business for 40 years
you can spell right away if it's gone
bad a good vanilla farmer can separate
good pods from bad pods right away
Meehan has to check his pots again and
again from harvest to export its tedious
work which can last up to a year he's
the biggest vanilla farmer in
sarahandaaron Oh every day he walks to
his plantation outside the village
when harvested the fresh fruit is green
vanilla plants belong to the orchid
family they grow in long ranks upwards
on supporting trees ideally in the shade
the plantation is busy all year round
between November and January the flowers
are pollinated every single one by hand
me and explains this extraordinarily
difficult process if you're not careful
when touching the flower you can easily
lose it that eats into profits five
kilograms of pods equals one kilo of
dried black vanilla that's a lot of
money
thank you divert kamsa don't include wah
maybe by the passage not surprisingly
there are a lot of thieves too who break
in and steal the green fruit it's a big
problem here Pina disappear speed put
vanilla vanilla to limit their losses
Meehan and other vanilla farmers have to
harvest earlier too early when the fruit
is not even ripe that hurts quality
whereas thieves have it rather easy they
have no trouble finding buyers for their
stolen pods it's fast money
back on the farm things are hectic
vanilla is very sensitive to rain we
have to bring in all the pods before it
starts raining or we lose the harvest
the freshly harvested vanilla is being
prepared for cooking the pods are put in
hot water to start the fermenting
process that's how the green husks turn
into the black spice now the poached
vanilla is wrapped still warm
every step of the process takes a lot of
experience every step for the two years
it takes from flower to pod the Sun is
up again Meehan takes a deep breath what
he smells is the smell of vanilla the
smell of Christmas